one of the biggest culprits in the
government staying closed now into week
for almost edging into week five I'm
having sort of a little trouble keeping
track at this point is Senate Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell somehow Mitch
McConnell has mostly managed to stay out
of the news and the headlines have been
all about Trump Chuck and Nancy but the
truth is that McConnell deserves a lot
of the blame for the government
remaining closed for as long as it has
because Democrats have passed Republican
bills in the house which Republicans
could have passed in the Senate if only
Mitch McConnell had actually put them up
to a vote Republicans could have passed
bills that Republicans negotiated with
other Republicans if Mitch McConnell had
put those bills up for a vote but
McConnell is effectively being a tool
for Trump mostly though he's not
suffering in the media he's not putting
the bills up for a vote and people
aren't even really noticing although
people are starting to notice after he
did this again yesterday Senate
Republicans have once again blocked a
house-passed bill to reopen the federal
government this was a package of bills
which would fund the Department of
Homeland Security through February 8th
it would fund the rest of the
departments that are shut down through
September 30th Democrats Chris Van
Hollen and Ben Cardin asked for this to
be taken up by the Senate and in comes
Mitch McConnell and he blocks it and he
says we are not going to participate in
bringing bills to the floor that don't
have a chance of passing
what McConnell means by that is that
Trump would veto it because it doesn't
include any funding for the wall so
they're just not even going to bother
but this is playing very coy and
McConnell really should be called out
for this because if it's just House
Democrats that pass something there's
not that much pressure on Trump and
Republicans to go forward because you
know what it's just House Democrats even
if their previously Republican
negotiated bills if the Senate though
decides to debate and maybe even pass a
bill to reopen the government without
border wall funding Trump then is
exposed as the reason why it's not
reopening and that's bad for Trump
because it's the circle Republicans
won't debate a bill that Trump won't
sign trumps under no real
to sign a bill that doesn't get debated
nevermind passed by Republicans in the
Senate so there's this vicious circle
and what's always ignored or mostly
ignored in this discussion is that even
if from vetoes one of these bills you
can still get it passed and get
government reopened with a veto override
if the House passes a bill and the
Senate passes a bill and Trump vetoes it
the House and Senate can do what's
called the veto override they vote and
if they get two-thirds of the house and
2/3 of the Senate to say we override the
President's veto the bill still becomes
enacted and becomes the law and in this
case government would get reopened I
don't know at this point if Republicans
would come a ward in the house to get
the two-thirds unclear what would happen
in the Senate although maybe it's more
likely but this is a joke and Mitch
McConnell should be blamed for this
thing Trump started the shutdown he said
he would be proud to do it and he did it
but we've got to point the finger at
Republicans who could debate this bill
and pass this bill and override Trump's
veto in both the House and Senate if
they wanted they are the saboteurs here
and slick Mitch McConnell has mostly
avoided the consequences and stayed out
of the news he really should be in the
news because he is almost at this point
as much to blame for the government
staying closed as his Donald Trump one
of today's sponsors is privacy calm
slash Pakman this is a free service that
I've actually been using myself for a
while now and I love it you just take a
few seconds to link your debit card or
bank account to privacy calms mobile app
or browser extension for Firefox and
Chrome and what that does is allow you
to instantly create virtual credit cards
that are linked to your bank account so
that you're not actually putting your
real debit card number on the Internet
and you use these virtual credit card
numbers to buy things online and with
one click of a button you have the
ability to create multiple virtual cards
delete cards freeze and unfreeze cards
you can put a limit on a card so a
company won't be able to charge you more
than you
we want them to and it protects you from
being hacked it protects you from
company's being hacked which we've been
talking about for a while on the program
and it's perfect for signing up for free
trial somewhere if you don't want your
real credit card number to be exposed
and on file and their app and browser
extension let you autofill the virtual
credit card number into the credit card
field when you're buying things online
there are a ton of different advantages
to shopping and paying bills with a
system like this everything is totally
secure and encrypted and in some
situations you can earn 5% cash back on
your purchases it's all completely free
all you have to do is click the link
under this video to get started and for
a limited time everybody in our audience
who signs up gets $5 towards your first
purchase when you sign up using that
link below